do you do you think you want to keep
them fat so you don't have to compete
with them like subconsciously yeah the
other girls right because meet with who
though like why you don't think you got
completed yeah do you think you have no
competition I don't want to compete with
like why am I competing with them anyway
like it's not like it's not life or
death you know you don't think you have
to compete for a man not really that's a
privilege okay well I'll take that but
if there's less wills it might not be
awarded to you no because just as I said
just lucky for you lucky for you there's
a lot of girls Plumping themselves up
right now so just being in shape you're
like a juicy girl look at it look it
you're in the top like 30 just not being
fat
[Music]